Matt welded smooth clothes make you feel
good though like this Friday yeah all
down but until you died you want to be
comfortable but also bad welding and buy
some stuff go to Matt welding calm and
use 20% off using promo code Hannibal
and buy something just for that moment
you forget that we all die one day but
you know if we are gonna die if you're
gonna be a lot you want people to me you
want the flowers [ __ ] they were
small use a promo
[Music]
that that that that that that that that
if you check your mic one more goddamn
time welcome to episode six six six
celebration six episodes so anybody that
said I wouldn't make it past 12 you're
still right this might be the last one
Wow what am I talking about this is
we're here in Chicago it's me it's Toni
trim special guest my good friend
comedian Kevin Bozeman yeah I should be
called the gambia gambling friend what I
should be cause a gambling friend to
like I mean that's like that's if you
think about like boys right before it
but most of our conversation is very
concentrated yeah right
no do you'll do this show who you
rolling with right that's our
conversation right right we go you wanna
do the show
hey man who you like today that's weird
though that just gambling friend I think
friends you don't have to specify nah
man friends you all the time no man I'll
be think that but gambling you should
you specify gambling buddies
yeah I gotta mess if I can do gambling
buddies are some of yo like that's
that's really good friends like that's
special than a friend yes
now dude but then you'd have to start
classifying all your friends know you
don't but you don't I'm standing bet you
it's a special circumstance because [ __ ]
goes on in the gambling world no one
else would know about yeah their
conversations the him and I will have
that no one else will be privy to where
you going out with a regular friend and
you hanging out with them you go out to
dinner you'd be like oh yeah we went to
dinner we talked about this this this
and this I went out you and I would with
Hannibal yeah how'd it go it was cool
and then that's it yeah it was cool I
mean that's it it was a good time yeah I
had a today's uh
today's Thursday the what is today
Thursday to set 7017 yesterday had a
play on the Warriors that Warriors were
playing the Toronto Raptors the Raptors
had a tough game against the Cavaliers
and I have a 40 on the back-to-back
assume today that I have tired legs
coming to get four nights four games and
five nights two points Brett minus six
for the Warriors looks like a give me
looks like easy money but a lot of time
what'd you learn what gamble on sports
yeah some easy ones occasionally but
something the easy ones a lot of times
become chaotic so go to stay up 19 in
the fourth quarter and Sonic is up 19
and a an incredible series of events
happen where they win by exactly six
which is a push for anybody
there's listening it's 9:00 and again up
pushes when they did it was that's a
point sparrows -6 go to stay one by six
so no money moves either way if you had
if you had that bet but a lot of
[ __ ] had to happen in the final
minute for that to happen eight they
lost the lead and then Steph Curry or
somebody foul somebody why he was
shooting a three-pointer and then they
went down somebody missed a free throw
from Golden State and it came back down
foul somebody else it was a lot of stuff
and it I could turn around it was like a
turn around fadeaway three point I was
blind shot that they caught with him do
you normally don't call with 13 seconds
left from the team down by seven you
just go look dude we know you searching
yeah
was something with like autographs
sometimes you get a lot of rest then on
this it was so it was very good I'm I'm
I'm happy that it was a puss it was so
bad
it was so I'm waiting when Durant missed
that first free throw to make them when
they when they went up by seven I could
when I ate I was like man it shouldn't
matter because they gonna go for three
and then go grab the rebound game over
yeah but when he missed that free throws
like this this novel like the way this
feels it was it was it was very
stressful and it shouldn't happen like
that but that's game but that's so crazy
with get when they they get it exactly
right so many they just get the number
right or is right off by one or
something go that half point comes into
play I forget like that Oklahoma City
Houston game was two and a half and a
half Oklahoma City was favored about two
and a half I took the over on that 218
it was it was a tragic with over the
over is when you bet on the total amount
of points as a set total amount of
points was just 218 so you're betting
that both teams combined to score more
and Houston scored 30 points total in
the second half Dirty's it was like 68 3
and 1/2 I hope people soon incidentally
this seems like a totally different was
the Colin Cowherd show this what is this
happening right now yeah it was it was
it was a crazy little day man it was a
crazy little day you remember when I
first met you keV I met you you played
si you know is crazy is uh I just got
booked back there and in January I'll be
back at SIU and I got I was like yeah
dude that's where that's where we met
and then you told me he's trying to do
stand-up and I was just like you know
right I was like right young fella just
right that's what I say just right and
get
did I ask you for advice is a savior
just write like this value I came up to
me it was like unit songs you know I
remember I remember this vividly like
you get in your check and then they just
like see my head and it's smilin and I
want to do that I mean so then I saw me
Chicago Tommy Sullivan it is still like
one of my favorite jokes of yours you
know which one I know where you go you
meet a girl she's the kind of girl that
you can take home to dad so he can hate
it too this is my way I think this do go
make it
remember Hannibal's first rap joke Nelly
Nelly and the manicure itself might be
all my first thought was oh was it yeah
whenever and I was talking super slow
back there yeah I thought the super
duper stoner did the job and yeah Nelly
has a song way says I'm a sucker for
cornrows and manicured toes no girls get
that toes pedicure Nelly has so much
money that he could afford to get his
girl's hands put on their feet crank it
out but being Tigers like yeah this this
is rock yeah dude so that was what 13 14
years ago something like it it was right
in 2002 2003 so yeah yeah man go a
minute we got some we've had some
travels now on a three
yes I'm very excited about I think I'm
on I think I've done too much to one of
the the units and now I have to live in
it I like it a lot
oh you is I gotta go I got an arcade
game in there which one they one of them
with 600 games like oh like if they
might they'll modify it it's like where
they'll have the body of a typical
arcade game right modified and just put
a computer in there and then you have a
bunch of game so it's like eight
different Street Fighters Ninja Turtle
x-men simpsons games
what kind of are they Nintendo games
Sega games what kind of game oh is
arcade okay yeah so Wow you put quarters
in it just eliminates that's press Start
if you you could just beat up if you
want cuz they're a classic Scott is away
yeah pretty much anything except for
like like NBA Jam cuz that's a different
configuration anyways that's right
because this is a six button three on
three on top three on the bottom okay
some are space invaders Gallagher
bubbliest is flies [ __ ] so babies
what's it only cost 600 bucks so you
know so you not go and rent this place
out because of a video game I've always
had weird priorities and different
things that motivate me and it's just
something in my gut I feel more
comfortable having this play I haven't
had a place and I never had a place of
Chicago of my own for one I have
roommates that in in Logan Square
oh she's what moved in you in 2008 I had
two roommates but besides that in
Chicago I live with my parents so it's
just something calming man I think I'm
taking a drum lesson tomorrow
what there's a bombing at all
I'm in the same I'm just I'm just
feeling relaxed and I'm doing I'm doing
sitting trying to you know the out there
man something about having roots and I
feel you know I feel good I never felt
that New Year's a brainstorm okay
it's a brainstorm you have like once a
month tenant appreciation day you fight
them up and play video games yeah I'll
get some chips and snacks and drinks and
then they liked it I bet you'll be the
everyone will covet that place do we got
tenant appreciation day we go up two out
of those place we play video games we
ate chips and drinks and stuff you
should do that I don't want long-term
tenants I want I want just are you yeah
yeah yeah yeah when I'm traveling I'll
still Airbnb the spot that I really like
but I'm a hold that down I was is if
just feels good in that man you should I
did a good job you should you should
it's nice to have some stability when
you're back in Chicago it feels good
feel just not as sleeping at hotel air
house you went you start doing comedy
dude I proud I started in Wisconsin like
late 90s yeah I probably went on stage
and like 97 and then just kind of was
like yeah I did it
and then like 99 I started getting back
just started hitting the mic so I was
living in between Madison and Milwaukee
so I was just going back and forth was
I'm out of cinnamon what is that
Appleton no that's north that's north I
went because I went to college at
Wisconsin Whitewater you played ball
right yeah yeah for you two years at
whitewater two years of the junior
college in Iowa yeah so you have to
junior college they said let's bring him
to a real college yeah yeah I chose
white water cuz it was because I was
homesick at the time I got an offer to
like a spot in cop in Colorado I got an
offer a spot in like South Dakota but I
was just like man this is too far away
whitewater was two hours from from
Chicago yeah so I chose there you know I
just hoop man I never I was a three man
small for all four but I guard it like I
would guard the toughest dude on the
squad so sometimes I guard the
point sometimes I got it to fire could
you dunk that's the first moment that I
wish this is a video podcast outside the
Bozeman gave blush like you uh I got
blood do that and Plus that long arms I
got long arms yeah like my height you
know they say you're you whip your high
supposed to match it up I'm six five on
my arm lift it's like six eight okay so
I got that Scottie Pippen react you know
what I'm saying nice
so do you so you got those memories cuz
I'm I got one Sports memory that and it
was just it was like a last play where I
call oh say I have a Sports memory of
you and it's at the jumping gym where
you jump in and stuck to the side a
backboard and Dave don't even I saw the
video he wasn't even with us I wasn't
with you but I saw him no and I mean do
I saw it a lot though we went to sky
Zone and we'll jumping on trampolines is
it's hard to get your balance on
trampoline but what I'm bowlegged
pigeon-toed so when I'm jumping off I'm
coming off a little crooked so I don't
know how to save advantages as you guys
know you look super excited and slightly
disappointed at the same time super
excited and disappoint at the same time
yeah I mean it was it was fun but I just
I wasn't really prepped and I didn't
stress out and uh my inhaler was running
low alright go ahead
I digress so tell me tell me you're
super super dope I remember and I was a
football I in the park I was dope at
football amongst my friends wasn't like
my friends sucked but I was pretty good
that didn't translates a high school
football for whatever reason I blame the
coaches attack or touch football when we
were playing in the part was tackle
tackle football and I remember I was
went out for the pass and I one hand
caught it and then hit the dude that was
guarding me with my shoulder in the end
zone and I'll never ever forget that
oh nice I was maybe 13 14 you know I
can't make out where here probably all
right let it start early enough with
gear oh yeah so I needed a year to grow
so you got a crazy that's right
for three years and we were known for
Chicago Chicago sir
right and Chicago Public Schools is it's
the worst in the country it's not even I
don't even think that's an argument and
we won't strike just about every year so
we were scheduled to graduate so I ended
up transferring to the suburbs so I play
the Argo which is on 63rd and Harlem
yeah and I played there so I only play
one year of high school basketball but
that team with 26 and three at one point
we were we were 17 and oh and we were
ranked second in state and 18th in the
nation whoa and then we ran into lafon
zoe ellis oh that was the father after
by the Warriors right now he had where
did he get rowdy he went to northern
yeah he got drafted by okay so he was a
lottery pick like 5th pick overall so
they were the defending state champions
do and this East st. Louis dude like it
was it was just it was nothing but speed
and jheri curl juice all over the court
crazy
[Music]
they ran us out the gym and I remember
the Chicago sun-times was going it's not
that they lost its the matter and what
they lost
so only three losses was tool Afonso
Ellis then we lost the dealer style
which is one of the best home courts in
a history they had a DJ and stuff
spinning yes my high school and then we
lost to Erik Anderson that go to state
Erik Anderson was a Big Ten Player of
the Year Erik Anderson and end up going
and being the first round pick for the
Knicks
I lost two NBA players um yes good but
at that time that you even see them and
like this dude is definitely going to
the league or you like man this dude is
just really good now you like having not
yet like that's like it's just if they
were if they were if Lafon joella's
could have went pro then out of high
school he would have went every Anderson
wouldn't have but the father would have
went straight out of high school you
know like he was just he was just a 6-10
38h 40 inch vertical dude just turn
around no matter where he's that he
still managed to dunk like just like do
you at the three keep no way you Duncan
this and he's his pump fake spin dunk
yeah yeah yeah
do you remember Amari Soria yeah it's
late for King he uh I forget what grade
school he went to but my team in either
fifth and sixth grade seventh and eighth
grade no its fifth to sixth grade right
late against him and he uh you know his
fit to sixth grade basketball but he did
a move that we hadn't seen at that point
at our fitness six level that's what
we're he you know went to save the ball
out of bounds and then he threw it off
of one our players and then I was just
sitting in OH
he's different from without that CBS he
was in our conference so we went up
against Marcus Liberty and it was just
like dude what is it Co fast forward
what is going on he was just playing a
different game yeah like the game just
was going so slow to him he could do
with everyone he was just dribble seemed
like he was slowly shoot everything he
did was just pitcher ass dude and you
just knew he was he was just better than
everybody else you knew that dude was
going pro yeah Tim Hardaway was in that
conference
Marcus Liberty was on conference Nick
Anderson was on conference Ben Wilson
was in our conference so yeah I had to
transfer to the suburbs I get some clock
yeah it was I play when I played
football it was some dude
from Hubbard and Hubbard has sent a
couple guys to d1 and and and a purl I
forget this dude's name but he was the
running back and he's just it's horri
he just tore us up man he was first
round playoff game like why is he so
different from us files and they do run
a four seven is a huge is a huge gap you
run for seven you got no chance to
making it running back give you four or
five that's that's when they just start
to look at you yeah yeah you run a four
or five alright let's let's take a look
at them you run a for seven years like
dude you better be a tight end or
something there's no way you're running
back yeah so yeah man just split seconds
man but yeah man that's good like you
and then we never I hosted the Bostick
competition that you did the Boston
Comedy Competition oh yeah back in I
know seven or something like that yeah
man that's yes those competitions man
they like I feel like it's a good way
for you especially the long in the game
to know exactly where you at and
stand-up comic competition is a weird
man
so exactly I got anxiety the format
obviously and the stakes are something
that gets an audience that probably
wouldn't normally go see this lineup of
people at a show but it's always a
contest so is this energy right but so
many different factors that can really
affect your high what was the crowd
feels you what was your game plan
McDaniels just try to do it good said I
didn't really have any gears back then I
don't think I just had like I got these
jokes these are my best
I got about 15-20 minutes of good jokes
and I think I was doing that miles think
I was probably doing eight minutes set
in the competition so that was the that
was it like I'm gonna do this I didn't
have you know strategy I'll try to hit
him like this or that it was just these
are the jokes I have and I hope they
like what if you obviously you ain't
doing that boy and highest like what
would you tell someone now
you if they were doing a competition
well I got this I mean if you have
something that I mean some of the best
sets or some of the sets that flown the
does this had a good flow is uh ones
that where I say something that the
there's addresses that town or that
crowd or that situation right right away
before I get into my regular would
cereal if you have something just off
the top of sector and and then and
that's more in a set feels more natural
that kind of is a good good way in
that's obviously if you could do sets
without that but that gets you in kind
of smoothly like where you know it does
it that's one thing I mean I joke about
it where you know sometimes starting out
like what this was starting out of
stand-up set is one of the most
artificial things right you can do start
just hitting the stage and then you're
talking like yeah I'm married
oh [ __ ] what the hell is going on in the
world uh yeah you notice you're just
going straight in siddhis this thing yes
you just starting out just really in
touch yeah so is if you can actually get
into it I think it's actually funny
sometimes what comics just do when they
just go up there so let me tell you but
my wife yeah it'll be thinking about it
is that really what I want to say to
them do I really want to talk about
Amtrak right away like that's that
what oh man I'll just get on stage so I
drink [ __ ] up right now I know I'm
drunk right now so I'm go to it um I was
a virgin until I was 24 let's talk about
it yes for those competitions always say
this like it's don't feel compelled to
do
you like your best material feel the
thing that a little chunk of a set that
says something about you that you could
put together for three and five minutes
we're just sounds natural as opposed to
you know everybody like you said you
take your best jokes and then you mash
them all together like here they go and
then sometimes it comes out I did I
didn't do last up useful about this this
last one was was pretty fun i mean like
audition in chicago they like me they
flew me to New York audition in New York
and they like me they flew me to LA I
got to be in LA for like a week a week
and a half like that was it was great so
you know I got TV time out of it sure
you go up there and they say go you got
a time in like three it's three three
and a half minutes and as you know we
never do to be funny to like my 20th
minute saying like I was just like all
right I'm just gonna talk about this
section that's going on in my life and
then this section that's going on my
life so i compartmentalize like that and
they have like they have to do a quitter
set comedy do they have like a clock
ticking down like 30 29 28 and they're
like the mic will be cut off you look I
mean it if do I know I have to do it if
I'm prepping a little bit I know you
know if I have a way to time myself like
that's something you've got a really you
can't do that okay just give me the
light at 2:00 and I'll close it up right
but you got three and a half minutes set
you have to even create nice set you
only get five and a half right five and
a six right but you run it you stuff
right and a half minutes times like a
breath a breath counts as part of your
set you guys why you can't take that's
why you can't take that [ __ ] too serious
you get what you can get out of it and
if not blaming you just you they give it
to you you try to squeeze some orange
juice out of it and then you just
whenever they good alright that's it
like you can't three in that minutes
like whatever like I'm running 45
minutes our sets every week gets let's
run no sense also it's a ton of
so they they they guessed it it's cast
it you know where they write they do
this
things were I've seen and heard that
they will you know manipulate audience
response and ahead it and try to flip it
like I've heard about people right by me
then people bombing and then they flip
it in an edit and make it look like they
killed just to move them along to have
right there and they think they gotta
happen
it's an NBC national show so let's say
for example the ten funniest people that
audition were ten white women they not
gonna have ten white women as your
finalists we gotta have some minority I
got some dudes they gotta have some
weird goofy characters today like you
said they're they're casting a show but
it does help if you're funny
who's the dude it was the white guy that
got adopted by a black family or
something well he was had a bunch of
white oh he had a bunch of I think
talking about the blindside
that's the Michael no I'm sure I forget
this guy's name but he was really funny
on it this comedian that just had all
black older brothers and sisters or
something I don't know exactly how it
happened I remember I remember watching
him that's interesting and then just
looking at looking up his life last
season I think it was last season yeah
man
yeah I thought lost I stopped watching
so I don't know I couldn't but yeah I
don't know who that is yeah I always
loved competition for a man that's
probably why I still put a little little
something on games yeah the competition
I live vicariously perfect amount of
time for you to get with no lie close
and really nail it
I like now dude I just feel like like
when I'm hitting the 40-minute mark I'm
starting to get into my groove yeah you
know I'm saying like I'm starting to get
into my group like I mean if you tell me
to do a half hour twenty minutes they
either of course but like that like I
like to do
like I like to do an hour I think I told
you this this was a few years ago I was
like dude you got to start just bring it
get rid of that three-man [ __ ] just
bring one person with you it just makes
it bad like you get to it that person
goes up does 20 I mean you just go up
and do and do your thing and it's if you
feel good about like were you writing
what you have to say I just feel like at
hours like as a great is a great time
it's a great amount of time is lik it's
like a thing it's not how do you like I
didn't you know I could I don't wanna
bother somebody last cuz it was a last
minute gig so I didn't wanna hit some I
up giant drive down the champagne and
then also I didn't know their local
scene like that you know to be honest
you know I wasn't feeling that generous
I think I'll just go knock it out and do
how much have you do was I think I'm
just too much a little it's like I feel
I'm feeling it
I gotta cut down to about that hour ten
hour five mark so it's some some phatso
cuts uh but it I got these I got like I
like all the jokes that I'm doing yeah
yeah that's that's I feel like you
should like that comes with being able
to read the crowd where you go alright
I'm doing an hour and ten and I'm
sitting on an hour thirty here and then
it's up to you to figure out which
fierce crowd and this show which ones to
be like alright you I always look at my
my jokes as a squat yeah it's my roster
y'all on the bench and then at some
point I like go alright you I need you
yes for this crowd you go in you can't
go thirty like you used to
you can go in and give you a bucket
right here the transition right and
there's something else so that's how I
look at my set it's just like as a squat
I cut that story about the graduation
story guys you know I think that might
be I might do that also
else's stories on the podcast see so
still streaming service it's great
ad-free got all the [ __ ] on there 30
rock parks recreation late 1970s late
night Jimmy Fallon all the schedules
every episode has an L it's killing me
right now to be doing this ant instead
of watching myself on seesaw
but life is life and I got kids to feed
right now guess what you get two months
free of C so two months free if you use
my promo code Rambler at checkout go to
see SOCOM s ee s o comm slash grambler
and sign up you get two months free what
C SOCOM promo code rambling two months
free now if you don't want to do it make
sure you cuz sometimes if you got that
auto-subscribe [ __ ] all they're gonna
get your credit cards and you forget
about those and that's how a lot of
business prosper because people could
get and you they just hit you slowly and
they do that to a lot of people and
that's how they built their money so if
you don't want it afterwards take just
remember to cancel that set that
reminder you got there following well
for now you see so calm and use the
promo code rambling for two months free
[Music]
dude I was I was there when you threw
our first pitch for the White Sox game
did draw a first pitch for the whites
who were practice in my yard remember
yes I went to the store cuz you know
what I got that you know I got to throw
out the first pitch this cuz uh somebody
at the White Sox was a fan it's the dude
that's a comedian now John
Margo loose key and I think and so he
was offense so initially just invited me
to the game and offered me in my family
tickets I said sure and then he said you
want to throw out a first pitch all
right and this is what was this 2011 so
just drop your first special didn't you
no yeah no yeah I think it may be later
that year or something I recorded it but
I was doing well in the city where I was
you know I was doing two weeks at the
comedy club I had you know I sell
tickets at Zanies
that type of thing but definitely not do
some weird some weird
first pitch thing with three of us threw
out the first pitch it was me
I wanted to receivers for the Bears and
then just some some older white dude I
don't know what what he did but he
jewelry store he threw the best he threw
the best out of the 70 year old man
threw that [ __ ] right down a minute
about 63 miles per hour and I got
introduced to the when they say from
Saturday Night Live in 30 rock Oh
Demetri
please welcome Hannibal Buress and you
hear eight five collapsing and you could
hear my is a video videos online of it
you can hear my dad because I'm trying
to make it funny but uh some some up
there so I'm looking off first base and
you can hit my dad
ain't nobody over that man
I did I did the UH the Charlotte Knights
which is the White Sox Triple A team and
I was out there and I was supposed to
throw the first pitch then I got bumped
by Cam Newton I was like all right
that's cool yeah but they still get the
interview with me and they had me on
their big screen I'm like yeah interview
me don't know buddy
yeah Charlotte like anybody understands
going around I need to know more about
kevie buzz let's get on with the game
come out to the show
yeah always be some free food my dogs I
want my hot dogs way that was their big
scream and they interview me I'm sitting
there with that now so we're really
talking about are we really talking
about yeah I just you know on the road I
think it was was this Houston or Dallas
or something and one of the one of the
local comedians you know you know being
a host yeah we're going to club going
and we go to his club and his funny when
somebody gets you a shout-out from the
DJ right yep all right nobody give thank
you thank you thank you yo man we will
talk about on the last episode it'd be
interesting to have some outside
perspective I'm not doing this to fish
but I think it was it was a very
different weird set at tonic room last
week yeah where I I thought I was just
doing a comedy set and then the band
state there so I had to work with the
band and come up with some originals I
didn't have to come up with original
songs but I I did some songs man and it
was you know I mean my I was I felt
under pressure
yeah cuz I feel like this is an
opportunity for me to really make my
name in Chicago hip hop and so I felt
pressure to perform mm-hmm chance rapper
was there right members of his band was
there other musicians GLC yes so I was
just trying to south spin bars man
I was just trying to do I so you're what
are you asking me is asking for your
outsider's perspective my perspective is
in a situation like that you you you you
think with your guns on that one you
crank out your material and you use the
band to enhance what you what you're
doing this is use your bands it's like I
back there you know and here's the joke
about pop pop pop pop pop kick this [ __ ]
and then they bang do something and then
the end you go and riff after you have
shown you destroy but it's fun dude it's
definitely it was definitely fun like
right for like I came with some some hot
hooks man I forgot I forgot where you
was we told the crowd to shut the [ __ ]
up I think that was yeah that was that's
it yeah the dope beat yeah that's what
it was I was trying to when I would try
to get into stand-up at some points it
wouldn't work at all you know they okay
time for a song that's he I felt like I
felt like you had a you had a couple of
a bits because that's because you was
you was just throwing off bits but he
wasn't you have a this like we talking
about you didn't have a set I bet you if
you did a set and then just even if you
would be like I'm about to do my
Letterman set but there's gonna be
different cuz I got a hip hop now you
now you freestyle that's also what kind
of put me off because it was a very
phones out crowd and so I don't like
doing rights that set with it everybody
back to be uncomfortable yeah I'd rather
wrap you so that's probably that's
probably plays into you to to your game
plan when you step in and do off shows
like that right well guys got it was a
lot of I mean cuz it was only about 50
people there and I'm right when I went
onstage at least 10 out of the 50 had
the falls out and then I kind of like
okay all right y'all ready get these
bars
[ __ ] lefties bars for I'm gonna do an
album I want to do album and I'm gonna
write a movie I need to write a movie he
talked about that he talked about that
dude him and I we I always like to
always throw out [ __ ] did I see cuz
we're not like I see him and then I
don't see him that I see him again
and so then I always just you know Manik
give like a like an update of what I've
noticed about you but i'ma tell you man
when we were in Oakland after we did
those tacos and we went to that bar what
was it was yeah we were Oakland right
because we were doing San Francisco
later that night and we went to that bar
and has some some cocktails laughter
yeah like that's just that was just like
all right we were just talking about
things about like we're talking about
clubs and theatres like you know you how
many clubs you should do and theaters
are talking about dope spots were you
also talking about like wait what you
need to do the push you talk about you
need to write a movie I was like what's
gonna be about I'll know but I don't
know I don't know I need a movie there
was something else that you said that
you you wanted to do where he was
actually thinking about taking a spot
out there for like a couple of weeks
just to write oh yeah I still want to do
that could when it get cold in Chicago
kick it at his winter in Chicago again
you and Kumail just gonna get together
and come out bail is because he lives
out there come on got two kids some
perspective do yeah it's okay to kind of
micro-irrigation giggling just
appreciate super families that I've seen
I've seen what is understand the dynamic
a tone sounds very dismissive it does
but I just I do I do get what you do I
get it you were your kids
I get it can't okay I get what you do
you and your kids I get it like I've
never seen people with you I bought it
but you know
I was out on the south side a couple
days ago well yesterday [ __ ] was
yesterday I was on the south side and so
my little cousin my little cousin James
was actually the one from you you know a
joke when I say my cousin I got a cousin
like a Hannibal I saw y'all yield tow
that wasn't funny man right you know I
gotta get him back like what would you
jack it off no it wasn't so that that's
so and so I think he from what I hear
from other thing he didn't you know he
didn't want to come around or come to
shelves cuz of that joke or something
he didn't pour ha yeah yeah how does he
he night 24 25 but he just had a baby
and I didn't even realize that that's
why he didn't soak all right you him
having the baby allowed me to reach out
a man congratulations on a kid and drive
through I just went to went to the store
just just bought a bunch of diapers and
bottles and [ __ ]
he bought me a Sonicare water pick good
I got the diapers and bottles and baby
wipes it's functional we do you drink
anything else except for Jameson we
should drink like we think about
Halloween another week another wheeler
sometime you're trying to try to give me
a new sponsor okay no you trying to
Aleut me for us no no no no no no no no
I would never we you know we always
boozing it up oh yeah you do drink
tequila occasionally tequila I have some
Bloody Mary Oh
Klose
[Laughter]
shouts out the L man crush on al Jackson
man crush on al Jackson and how much of
a man he is that weird all right
maybe it's weird y'all the only two
people has been on the show besides me
and Sony and Mark is briefly oh yeah um
I don't have that many guests cuz I want
to feel like I'm bothering people with
me I don't wanna I don't like asking
people I don't know that I get that you
know what I'm saying
I got if I notice my really well I don't
want to be I don't want to get back you
know yeah I always get that feeling like
always sometimes you'll do something
then I'll go yeah I bet he's gonna ask
me but I just don't know when like I
swear like I was I was like right before
I go ah he should be calling me pretty
soon about the Chicago theater like you
know I mean we drove up and did a
Rochester right Chester Rochester
Minnesota home of the Mayo
all clinic and you've done you've done
my mic a beat my Thanksgiving show three
times now Oh huh three times so three
times doing stuff man you know I mean my
main my main thing my main regret in
life and I don't even know if it's
fixable at this point is that I can't
parallel park at all except that one
time when we we put a wager on and you
parallel park all right something I
think I'm like 5050
listen you I have a genuine it's a fear
I don't know what it it like if there if
I if I pull up to a spot and there's
traffic behind me and it even if there's
a spot right there
I got panic and I just go around a block
that's because with the years are you
supposed to be becoming a driver you
gonna end up being you spit in New York
so you know yeah the drop the the
formative I'm about to knock this
parallel Esther [ __ ] out we have been
and getting out of a cab oh that's
really 1920 so Oh to 205 I had a car and
that's it right they say you know it's
become a good driver until like after
ten years and you sacrifice those years
and when you were driving he was getting
in a rental car and driving to a school
or to a spot and run really any real
parallel parking issues so now you know
all right but whenever I with you you
always defer driving nothing to do with
that wheel do occasionally I Drive
sometimes I liked it I liked it but it's
just a park and I hate the parking yeah
I don't know Kate but you can't just say
you can't just take a parallel parking
class as a 33 oh man can you I know you
got to get behind the wheel man I know
just keep practicing like get out
I think we're on the same spot yeah go
to another spot parked there pull out go
to another spot park there pull out to
spend the day doing that you'll get it
done rocky it's all in the mechanics man
your body will just get used to it you
ever yeah
see somebody parallel park in this bag
you just laugh at them and you they they
can't do [ __ ] with laughs back why they
screaming upstairs well no I don't laugh
at anybody
cuz that could be me I see myself in
them I've I've cracked up I've lost my
[ __ ] on people especially when they got
nice cars and this is awful parallel
park and I'm like you suck at very
little parking yeah I'll be trying to
just sometimes I just want people to
know that I'm that a cow get a nice
rental car sometime and so I want people
out my Park could be horrible and I
don't want people to think that a
parking horrible cuz it's a beds I was
parking horrible kind of a bad Parker it
would be parked like that if it was a
Ford Fusion or a Toyota Prius or any
other car that wants to sponsor this
podcast do podcast get sponsored by cars
ooh ooh / / that's Nana that's
technology though man that I that's your
podcast and this is the story is a
little ridiculous but I have to tell my
New York story can I tell it what just
happened
it just happened recently yeah I got it
no I got it when I was in New York last
remember I did the didn't factory yeah
whatever
so I was doing a gig and Massachusetts I
was doing a college and right outside of
Boston and I flew into New York because
I had some other gigs lined up and I was
gonna end up in New York so I get in I
rent a car I prepay for it but what they
don't tell you in New York is you can't
use a debit card
oh you can't use a dryer it's just state
of New York you can't use it was this
was thrifty yeah this was thrifty I had
no problem saying that so I get there
they won't give me a car I'm like what
are you talking about I prepaid for it
and they still won't give me a car and
I'm making a scene everybody there is
calling thrifty a piece of [ __ ] you
really yeah you you gave him a contract
he signed the contract
why would you take his money if you
can't accept it because I paid for with
the debit card and they're like okay we
can't it we gave it just fill this
paperwork out I was like all right look
just show us you got some money
all right cool I fill this out giving my
social security number my bank
everything giving this like a I what's
next a girl's this takes 30 days to
process and I say without mister to be
honest like all right now you guys are
just being [ __ ] I heard you behind me
go Jesus man go sir
I rented a car I pay for it they have my
car they make me fill out paperwork and
then tell me it takes 30 days to process
I go yeah [ __ ]
so now I can't deal there's no flights
real you would think flying in New York
to Boston it's like piece of cake
there's no real flights out there at the
uber it you did you were from New York
to Boston
are they from New York - just south of
Boston good a good card oh yeah yeah
dude like I think you came out like 400
fun yeah yeah dude I just over it man
shotgun huh you go second I was in the
back there sleeping I was so angry I was
so angry is writing me notes the thrifty
dude they and it says in fine print we
cannot prevent you from getting a car do
because you don't have a major credit
card it says that but still even like I
pay for it but then I had to corporate
online and like corporate all of a
sudden on my side and then they talk to
corporate I call corporate back he's
like yeah man we there's nothing we can
do about this I know I
as a reimbursement he goes actually we
charging you a cancellation fee what
they tried to be a cancellation fee and
said they were going to send me the
soundness of my check
so I be so I paid for the rental car
which they didn't give me and then I
dropped full on and something for the
uber damn that's crazy duh so what's up
we're done with thrifty everybody should
be done with Rizzo is no more thrifty
hopefully they not a sponsor
no unless thrifty unless thrifty is the
silent majority owner of skin condoms I
don't think I don't think we're
affiliated with them so DEET was your
driver psyched or do so you know they
don't know until they pick you up yeah
so he pulls up he goes hey we want to go
you want to go see Manhattan like I want
to go to st. Mary's or college or
something he goes that's not that's not
you have the wrong statement man that's
in Massachusetts and then I didn't say
nothing and then he went I gotta call my
wife like towing I was I do I gotta get
that now you need to make a decision
you said you know take me if you go take
me we gotta go yeah well that's what I
said I said before I hop in the car say
Amen
you know we going to Boston right just
okay cool yes it was like yeah cuz he
was like I was he goes it was so weird
cuz I was like I should pick up he was
debating whether or not to pick up one
more fair
various like I didn't even know if I was
gonna pick up a fare but I haven't that
but then I kind of find out a comic my
agent told me that the comic ran into
the same problem this dude made me feel
like [ __ ] because he went and rented a
u-haul truck a u-haul truck accepts
debit hand that written a u-haul truck
and in and drove the hell who's that uh
shoot Alvin something I forget right
that's that thing and I had a box but
yeah man two days doctor's appointment
on Saturday please oh no we don't have
Saturday it's three weeks from now
good no I'm gonna no I need I want to
see that I'm gonna see the doctor now
what happened and I saw you post about a
heckler story a heckler at a gig where
were you North Dakota last Fargo North
Dakota so what had you played there
before uh no I haven't is the new club
it's a small club it's in the hotel it's
a smaller spot thing I like loud western
Holiday Inn Radisson Radisson yeah then
it's a c65 and so I get up there and his
dude is drunk and he screaming stuff out
we have words
Macy's remember any one of his specific
screams his screams was you know I'm a
cook right okay I went talking about
cooking I went on my food you know I'm a
cook you see this [ __ ] like that he's
there he's there with his wife and then
another couple and I'm like dude I'm
going words with you I go I'll do this
all day I don't give a [ __ ]
it's only 40 of you here I'll do this
all day it's not like the club is taking
care of you and kicking you out like
they should so I gave him the notes of
it and then so to do the manager comes
right away and tells him he's got to
leave and he's like are you serious and
he goes uh and he goes uh what can I
come back
and I didn't mean like this they thought
he was just on time gonna say the time
out you does take some time I'll do some
dozen cocaine drink some water and
inspector sellout and become you come
back a better audience reevaluate your
life reevaluate what you need to do this
so anyway he gets kicked out you refused
to leave oh this is the middle-aged
white dude he's wearing a pink shirt
he's balding up top like I went them
like he didn't trim everything see I
like the hair all the way like of the
bow haircut but his ball in the middle
fusili they call the cops he pulls out
his phone starts video taping the cops
as if they gonna [ __ ] beat him up
what was he yelling at the cops I I'm
not leaving that you can't kick me out
this I paid money I'm staying here
I wanna watch the show I was helping I
was not a disturbance yeah he keep
suddenly he's saying it like so earnest
and really believes in himself just this
that he drunk oh yeah clearly he's
trying clearly drunk so he leaves with
his wife finally and another couple
sticks around and then after the show
couple comes how was the wife how was
with did she seem supportive or
embarrassed she was embarrassed she was
embarrassed he's and busy say what she's
saying like quietly like now she's just
come back I'm not to come back to that
because it doesn't in at the at the at
the club so the couple that he's wait
the woman comes up to me and the dude
goes up to the future I can a woman it's
like so I don't understand I understand
why you had to kick him out why couldn't
you incorporate him into your act was he
being that much of a disturb this is why
you're still this is after show this is
after the show the woman the friend the
friend of the couple so she comes up to
you yeah she's asking me why I couldn't
incorporate him I go I play with the
audience all the time but I don't play
with the audience when the dew tries to
make the show all about himself because
it's a distraction to everyone else who
doesn't really want to hear what he has
to say she's like well arey I go I go
this is she goes does this happen all
the time it's just new I go no this is
they tell you not to to talk before the
show she's like well I just don't
understand it and I don't get it and I
am thinking should I kick them out I
think if you were better at what you do
you could
may could incorporate it what I was just
like what about like lady hanging a
little drunk at this point to you a few
it now no okay though
so you do you have it with grace yeah
we're grace grace grace and then the
next show there's a chick that's there
this drunk and I do incorporate her into
our hacking I want to be like go get
that so we go to the bar a half block
down and this place is a band down there
it's packed it's like a VFW hall can
this Fargo North Dakota it was also a
club we got out stairs the band plan we
get drinks and out here's all man the
dude that got kicked out is right behind
you and he's staring at you so dude he
he's got his arms look like sprawled out
and he's just mean mugging like like
he's leaning on the bar leading on the
bar just there me mugging the [ __ ] out
of me yeah his wife is over there to the
side hyperventilating she's just like
breathing you can tell she's not making
eye contact how does this dude about it
i'ma say early 50s oh uh early 50s so I
could have easily turned him he's like
fat he's fine I think yo five six are
very flat but the host the host is a
little Middle Eastern duty so maybe five
six he sees him as well and then he rose
around and then just Kraus the the host
and he's just staring at him like he's
got his arm up against the wall and he's
just staring and the host or tried to
scoot over the host were trying to scoot
over
and then he would he would follow him
like scoot with him I did not give him
space so I'm hostess kind of just he
just like oh this is awkward and he's
not confronted dude and he's just moving
on if he woulda turn to come to confront
him they would've bumped heads that's
how close man he's in he is in his
personal space I grabbed the hose after
laughing for like five minutes I just
come over here by me so then he tries to
come up by me where you're from
what
with the initials on your hat blah blah
blah blah and he's like trying to body
up I'm like dude I'm not backing up dude
you gotta help and then security comes
and separates us and then the his wife
says to me as he walks away why'd you
have to make me look like the [ __ ] -
and then storms off that's like it just
no one have accountability and the whole
time he was doing circles like hiding
behind a wall I mean just to mean mugged
me we just hide me on the walkway around
the wall just that mean mugged me do
crazy uh yeah that's they got some other
stuff
dude no more hope no one take
accountability for anything nowadays I
think they were accountable in there but
just you know you know you just wrong
and you just like I'm going down this
I'm going to kamikaze this wrong I'm
going down with this ship I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna force it and and that's
that that's oh that's crazy
awful what's it wish your worst I wish
it were as heckle experienced oh I got a
bunch we all do we same one that's that
sticks out it's just one what is it one
thing that I don't like if I run into
them afterwards I don't like them trying
to if I if I spot them as the heckler
right I don't want them to buy you a
drink oh don't I don't I'm not taking a
drink for you first of all I'm getting
my [ __ ] for free probably so right thank
you but also not from you I don't want
to take a drink from you also don't ask
me to take a picture after you identify
yourself as somebody who fed up
interrupted the show several times I
also don't approach me like we're
[ __ ] comedy team like we see
what we see what we did out there no see
what I I could do this I was able to
work in spite of you not because of you
I mean so is this funny sometimes we do
I was part of it yeah you were but it
was yeah you know don't don't be so
don't be so proud and they'll come up to
me like we bout to just go kick it and
I'm just about to hit the town
and I'm like eh what's up y'all it's me
it's the heckler bottles in this [ __ ]
right now
and plus you're enabling them because
now that dudes gonna be like oh [ __ ]
that's just what you do so go to the
next comedy show and be like he he
probably was at your show and you
incorporate him he's like I did it at
halibel show why can I do the bozo nose
so funny I got DMS and people after one
that shows this past weekend and it was
one of them was a girl I was the one who
yelled out such as such let's meet for a
drink no no that's not how I hang out
with people
oh yeah let's meet for a drink I was the
one that yeah but I have heard also like
in as far as comedy clubs about
comedians ended up [ __ ] their
hecklers [ __ ] because it's mostly chicks
I think it's mostly try to make them cry
in crotch other woman I try to ruin
hecklers like I try to see cuz the one
thing to it when you if you go hard on a
heckler depending on what your you know
stage persona is I just I remember early
on just in a couple times I was just
where I didn't you know I handled it but
I didn't handle it that deftly right and
so I was shut the [ __ ] up you need to
shut us up so get you ass parent so uh I
was coming out is what you raise breast
lifts you kind of you know comedic lien
just onstage kind of locked into her
energy and then you go off a snap on
somebody and it just rots we're back
right I had a host I had a host do that
for me once the Milwaukee County cafe
he's trying to get this do to shut up
he's like sir shut up I'm not playing
sir shut up this is your last warning
guys you're gonna love your headliner
hahaha sure I'm not playing shut the
[ __ ] up
you know Comedy Central ugly Jesus
Christ dude yeah yeah I when I first
started I was in Davenport Iowa at the
funny bone out there and I was hosted
and it was packed and his woman screams
out speak up [ __ ] oh that's him and
they come to find out that she could
kick that immediately but it was in the
paper the next two days later it was at
a paper because she was the manager in
charge of the minority program at her
social Social Work job
what fired immediately well well how do
I have something crazy to tell you was a
you remember the other day well when we
were driving back the other day I told
you that guy had come in and bought all
that he was like a buyer for that talent
and he bought all that clothes yeah he
put all your clothes on eBay no he turns
out to be a professional identity theft
thief yeah bro he ran off about with 30
grand of gear from my shop wait he
didn't yacht in Sharjah let me explain
to you so this guy so I have a men's
store at Logan Square this guy came in
he's like so I wasn't there my partner
know was there and he was like so he
pulls up like in a three hundred
thousand dollar Tony just two-foot
context tony has a shop in Chicago Logan
Square maven they have some nice hip
items most of them are very expensive
yeah so thanks for putting in that last
anyways no it's not baby so this guy
comes in right he comes he drives up
like in the $300,000 whip and he's got
like a six sixty thousand dollar watch
and he's you know he's staying at the
Waldorf allegedly 60,000 yeah well I'll
see it no I mean no aside no one no
one's gonna clock in that Kruger
nice probably no one's gonna clock in
that kind of stuff anyway said the grass
okay say pocket something go ahead
anyway this guy well this guy is a
straight-up professional because he came
in all the IDS checked out all the cars
checked out everything checked out I
don't know exactly the extent of how
like how well it was it was done but I
do know that like so he comes back so he
comes the first time buys like 10 grand
worth the gear right yeah and he's like
send it to my hotel wall Waldorf Astoria
so you just like you're not gonna
question that is like staying in a nice
hotel he's pulling up and what they like
young-ran the car ran the car everywhere
oh yeah everything was good yeah so he's
like next level I'd you know identity
thief like people like this exist right
next day he comes back drops another 10k
he's like but that he's a thing the
people that he were meant he was
mentioned it wasn't like oh I buy for
Drake I buy for cut it wasn't even like
that he was like yeah it worked for a
little bow-wow Bobby Portis and pajkatt
said when you said bow-wow but you had
you know I'm saying but you know he's
like he represented himself as just like
a like my seat goes he's got clients
I've noticed like lions like that he cuz
I mean Schaben foot bow-wow and Chicago
Bulls Bobby Portis at the same time
she's like a nightmare small you know if
he was like talking about like big
people then you could probably research
and find that [ __ ] out bright you know
what I'm saying Bobby port is his
business not out there like that
especially not a little bow-wow
Oh Bobby Portis this is second year he
died using like such stylists already
yeah there's this this guy wouldn't even
he didn't present himself as a stylist
it's just as a buyer as a buyer yeah
like so his hustle he explained it as
like I buy clothes at 20% off cuz I'll
buy him bulk from you guys will give it
to you at discount 20% and then he makes
that off Commission by selling it to
full price but those guys you know I'm
saying he'll go and pick the fly stuff
our but he was but that's the thing he
was picking them in specific sizes he
was like he had everything covered like
super meticulous
yeah you know I'm saying and then
another 10 and then another 10 and then
the next day we get a call from one of
the credit-card company he's just like
so I was going on with this transaction
like [ __ ] you talking about and then no
but like ensure I've got all the
insurance but but it's crazy to know
that there's a human being there's human
beings out there that do like he had
everything covered like all of his bases
were covered okay hey I hate to ask this
but what color was he he was black it
was like he was like it was like a early
in his early 30s
he's a very well-kept very you know
dressed but I know it sucks but even so
like if I mean it's just me I had a
white guy pictured in my head to be
honest [ __ ] so did I but like we're not
bow-wow Bobby Portis yeah but the way no
one knows would like white dudes to buy
[ __ ] for oh man but he was like dropping
names of other shops he was like he knew
what he was like he did you could tell
he did some serious research and so and
there's no chance of catching this dude
he's gone I mean this this could be
easily like a federal case like we could
bring the FBI into this because it's so
crazy um like it just straight up like
yeah y'all got a camera that's what's
[ __ ] up is our ATT thing for some
reason like the surveillance was down at
the time so like we have no images of
him nothing he's do nothing on the
streets and nothing nothing nothing dude
ghost yeah what about the store next
door the bar may I mean maybe maybe they
might have something but even so like we
call call the cops the cops like no no
we can't do anything about it that's
between you guys and the credit card
company credit or the the person owns
the credit card they're the ones that
have to file a police report they're
like we can't do nothing for you also
you damn yeah so it's like 4:30 jeez
yeah I mean obviously like we have
insurance and stuff that's gonna cover
it but at the end of the day is like
this there's a human being out there
that does like it but he did it in such
an intelligent and smart manner that I
feel like he could have probably
we applied that to something else and
been successful here he is a deviant
yeah that's where those people are they
deviants people that they can that's
really smart and know how to plan and
connive their deviance is one thing
people there's fuck-ups and then there's
people that just consciously decide to
do bad [ __ ] yeah I mean also he was like
probably like the host of The Apprentice
is president a definite Casillas 30
racks worth of clothes sunglasses
watches wallets like just everything
like he just he went in man okay I seem
like that type of person does cocaine
right I bet you that dude is straight
Perrier water he's from what I know from
all the information that I've [ __ ] yeah
like he's Hans got exit it got exit out
got people that that looks out for you
own high-end men's clothing store and
it's a dude that's buying a bunch of
stuff it says he works for bobby portis
that is a fraudulent that is a
fraudulent situation that you don't want
to be a part of that if you see that man
then email us at the handsome ramsey
calm the hands of Rambla gmail.com and
tell us about your interaction with him
and get pictures yeah and get pictures
and and then all of that stuff yeah and
you know still uh still some Tony starts
back he's but if he's that if he's at
your bar by top-notch alcohol talking
about he's represents Bobby Portis that
dude you know he ain't just buying
clothes he probably doing it all if he
stayed at the Astoria right he's doing
it he's living he's guy he probably got
that watch with that and to be able to
know exactly how long he can say and how
long he can do something cuz if you stay
at the hotel Astoria right for three
days he's probably got some sort of
mechanism of dawn we're gonna find out
you probably know when they're checking
their credit card - something's like I
gotta bounce
I'm out this off like what like two
decades ago when there was no internet
you think he could have pulled this off
back then with the cards yes you can not
get caught right way back credit card
fraud I do so like have even now I mean
I go to a lot of places I use my credit
card and not just hand them a credit
card and they swiped a credit card
they never is no fair unless you try to
rent a car from thrifty
occasionally at a store dealt but a lot
of times just smaller purchases of [ __ ]
right I just swipe that [ __ ] man yeah
you know so I still truly in my heart
and my brain I don't genuinely
understand how credit card technology
works what's up with that show or to get
it I get that the information is there
and next month I but I just I just
accept it for what it is and I'll just
thank the Lord for all his blessings
thanks a lot y'all thanks a lot to our
special guests Kevin Bozeman Kevin you
want a bug man uh you know I have my own
podcast abajo yes on episode right yeah
with mine is more how we started out our
podcast that's kind of how mine is I
talk very sports meritorious oriented
yeah talk sprints and [ __ ] like that and
okay that Kevin bows but I can yo man
I'm diggin Instagram follow me on
Instagram km Bozeman 1km Bozeman want km
Bozeman one is on Instagram plz EMA
yeah don't tell me yeah what County
trail it's all the trend
Tony trail would like to plug the fact
that it's a bitch-ass [ __ ] out
there
I stole the Ganga clothes and he's not
very happy about it I'm Nettie that's
just come back let's pile dude we've
shared some foul [ __ ] my my uber yeah so
with thrifty you getting 30 G's and you
held on it I got something he told me
that Taj and Bobby were supposed to come
in the shop today I was supposed to be
there right now same thing have an
account on Kevin Aden had thing where
the dude was perpetrating like you know
Kevin Alton yeah yeah he was I had to do
as famous perpetrating like he was the
owner of the San Diego Chargers yeah he
came in and took Kevin dogs bar and
firing rounds for everybody showing
money showing flashing and then he was
like I got this
yeah I really like you dude I'm about to
branch off and do some other stuff here
in Chicago and I need you and Kevin on
beer some research call the FBI they did
this thing call them okay Kevin Jake not
the reward money so yeah it can't be
done can we then do it again caught up
but you can't use out he's definitely
got some jail time
yes soon enough can't live that life
like that however probably good night
you all drink a lot of water be cool
talk to your mom
happy holidays have a good time do some
push-ups watch your favorite television
show call somebody you haven't called in
a long time listen to your favorite song
30 times in a row
check me out I'll be in Australia
Australia soon so come through Brisbane
Perth Sydney Melbourne Adelaide later
good night in 1962 a mysterious
strangler committed the first of 13
random murders shocking Boston and the
world who were these women and why would
anyone want to kill them it was the
largest manhunt in the city's history
what is Mary Sullivan's picture doing on
the front page of the paper with the
Boston Strangler fifty years later the
cases remain open
Stranglers the new crime series from
Earwolf subscribe now in itunes stitcher
or google play this has been an ear wolf
production executive produced by Scott
Aukerman and Chris Banach the more
information and content visit Earwolf
com